we got a question right here what is
this note yes I did today does long
intro but we got some king of the sting
some debate club clown my hound if we
get to it and our new segment about up
in people's tinder profiles which I know
we could decide the the name of the
segment on-air we had some a lot of
submissions there was like one
resounding favorite but I don't know if
you guys had any suggestions for it what
was the what was the cinder my tinder
was overwhelming favorite okay makes
sense we torch the profiles build them
from the ground up there was also style
my profile singed my hinge hmm I also
saw shiver me tender shiver me tender
done I think it's it's fun so yeah I
think and I don't know if we can help
him where we can definitely say look
does don't do this you know I think [ __ ]
would want to help them I think we can
help them yeah that's what I mean I was
I was gonna save it till the end but
since that was such a long intro let's
get right to it
first we got suck suck was 22 years old
oh well we got change add a break huh oh
damn this is the kid from he's the bad
guy in venom he's also in that HBO
series I think he looks like that
movement trainer you don't you don't
portal dude I think sucks doing a nice
job here yeah I don't think he sucks at
all yeah he's climbing the wall there's
a wall climbing there is him with
sunglasses on looking cool looks like he
has a coconut water or his recently had
one he has toplessness and he has wet
body his body looks wet it's very wet
apparently works out and there's one
with him and um who's that guy Carson
Daly yeah it's hard to tell Peter that
some sort of Casa Bonita Mexican
restaurant he looks like a very friendly
dude and he's Mexican yeah yeah I'm
sorry I met Indian Osteria
with the Mexican guy when I said Sokka
is an Indian name that's just suck dude
no it isn't you think it sucker you
think the hottest a a fast sucker
so dude I'm Tony he looks like the bad
guy venom and then his written profile
says carefully written fact checked
essay in the streets on moderated
comment section in the streets mache -
creepy - cliche - Ryan me the girls oh
my god I like it that makes sense you
Ronnie
you think too much it's too much oh it's
like he's it's like he's pitching us
ideas for another segment idea we got a
rhyme everything dude we're not even gay
man dude cat what do you think how are
we knowing I mean I know dude photos are
good
I think the bio could use a little work
what do you think about the more human
in the bio man regular this shirtless
gym selfie like that seems like just go
to the beach you know a natural picture
were you sure yeah this is creepy no one
likes to get some working out and picks
up selfie in the marital body yeah boys
watered up pride you have a steam room
yeah and that's not a real workout if
you'd has been in the steam room Roman
and what to say my anthem the [ __ ] his
anthem to play a song now uh yeah you
can connect it to your Spotify oh wow
and can we here is it's not included in
the picture
um but look he's climbing the wall right
there obviously he's a active I would
say Kratts yeah I would say get some
pictures with some puppies some dogs
chicks dig dogs dude and their outdoor
activities that's indoor that's rock
climbing yeah it's indoor right it's
outdoors indoors I feel you it's
outdoors in don't where I was going yeah
it's like an you see like a lot of
plants indoors his profile needs more
real [ __ ] like carefully written
fact-checked essay in the streets on my
read comment section in the sheets he
looks like he's got some danger -
equally looks like he could be
someone who does danger from another
country as well yeah I get that vibe as
well he also looks like you being don't
[ __ ] with cats part but you mean like
parkour yeah yeah yeah I recorded
yeah like parkour he definitely seemed
like he could be good-looking dude you
shouldn't have too much problem 22 it
seemed like he would be like the bad guy
and like a lot of Trump campaign that's
fair uh but no look man I don't know I
don't I'm not trying to meet women out
here you know I I don't have any idea
and I'm not a woman I don't know I think
I do man yeah yeah make your thing more
friendly more and more relatable that
that weird [ __ ] you got written in your
bio ain't gonna work homeboy yes
pictures dogs they were the picture of
you in the gym right when you get done
working out no one likes that guy he
just seems a little too calculated that
does seem approachable yeah he's up dude
he's up dude yeah maybe have one of you
dancing with someone maybe have one of
you building something making like a you
know doing model cars or doing like a
donk yeah building something outdoors
fair enough
I think that's a good start and I think
to kind of improve the segment we could
have people include all their pictures
and send in a video saying like what
their experience has been on tinder what
they're looking yeah how's it been going
yeah yeah yeah cuz you're 22 I don't
think it's struggling to skinny titties
in his mouth I'm not sure I mean I'm not
attracted to the guy yeah I don't think
that this isn't gender we're not trying
to match you up with suka okay okay like
I might get you something what a great
name huh let's get luck ISM qinger is
saying it's I don't know if we helped
suck her or not
you did it look you're making a smart
move Chappelle I agree
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]